Ça va mieux ?
Parce qu’on est là, c’est pour ça.
Salut, c’est Riadh
et aujourd’hui, je vais vous emmener avec moi
avec les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris.
On va passer une garde complète avec eux.
On va voir ce que c’est leur quotidien
et on va voir aussi ce qui motive
les jeunes de mon âge
à se lancer en tant que sapeur-pompier.
Do not modify/translate
Donc les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris,
c’est une brigade assez particulière
par rapport aux autres pompiers
parce qu’eux, en fait, c’est des militaires.
Ça existe depuis très longtemps,
ça date de l’Empereur Napoléon 1er.
En fait, il a failli mourir dans un incendie
du coup, il s’est dit : "Ça serait bien de créer
des mecs qui te sortent de situations avec du feu."
Donc voilà, depuis ce sont créés
les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris.
Alors c’est comme tous les matins,
on a ce petit cérémonial traditionnel.
On se dit tous "bonjour" comme ça
on est sûrs d’avoir vu tout le monde.
- Qu’est-ce qu’on va faire, là ?
- Tous les matins on a une vérif
à faire de tous les matériels.
On a un ARI,
Appareil Respiratoire Isolant,
chacun, à mettre sur le dos,
ce qui nous permet
d’aller dans le feu avec.
- Ok, d’accord.
Comme un truc d’oxygène quoi.
- Voilà, c'est ça.
Donc ça se présente comme ça,
on va se mettre là-haut pour faire la vérif,
c’est tout le temps là-haut.
- Ah oui poste de vérification !
Quand il y a du feu, tout ça,
ils se mettent ça sur le dos avec un masque.
Vous mettez un masque aussi ?
Un masque aussi qu’on va ramener après.
C’est vraiment balèze,
tu mets un truc lourd sur tes épaules.
- 12 kg je pense.
- C’est quoi ? C’est le masque ?
- Vous voulez que je vous montre
comment on le met ?
- Vas-y, si tu peux me faire
une démonstration.
C’est parti.
On va essayer un masque en direct.
- Le masque. Ok.
Casque de protection.
- Toujours, la protection.
- En fait, ici c’est ce qui se branche
à l’ARI pour avoir l’air.
- Ok.
- D’accord ?
Je le tiens, je ne le lâche pas.
- On met ça bien.
C’est même plus dur
d’équiper quelqu’un, je trouve.
- On se sent un peu…
Tu ne respires pas comme d’habitude,
tu vois ?
Donc là, je suis en intervention là.
Plus le truc derrière,
ça fait 12 kilos.
- Voilà.
- Ça veut dire quoi ça ?
- Ça ? Stop.
- Et ça ?
- Avance.
- Oh ! Ça libère. Purée, ça libère.
- Bon moi, ma vérif, elle est faite.
L’ARI est faite.
On va aller faire un footing.
Je ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
parce que moi,
je suis sportif de base mais…
parce qu'ils ont l’air
un peu plus sportifs que moi.
- Pas de séance particulière les gars,
on fait des tours des Buttes-Chaumont,
allure classique...
12 km/h,
45 minutes, une heure à peu près.
- 45 minutes, une heure, c’est beaucoup...
On vient de recevoir un appel
dans le talkie-walkie,
je ne sais pas ce que c’est
comme intervention
mais on va partir là, direct.
On va voir ce que c’est sur place,
espérons que ce n'est rien de grave.
A1, sens province-Paris.
Là, on vient d’arriver,
il y a déjà un VSAV comme
vous pouvez le voir ici sur place
et on va aller voir ce qu’il se passe.
- De toute façon, à chaque fois
dans les accidents de voiture,
ce qui arrive c’est les cervicales ?
- Ouais.
Il faut aussi savoir qu’ils interviennent
toutes les 63 secondes en moyenne
et ils mettent environ 7 minutes
à arriver sur les lieux.
Donc, c’est du rapide,
c’est du direct quoi.
- Depuis ce matin,
il n’arrive pas à respirer.
- Baisse de tension ?
- Il a 11,7.
- S’il est à 100, déjà c’est qu’au niveau
de la respiration, ça va.
Mais j’aurais besoin qu’il me parle
et qu’il m’explique ce que
ça lui fait exactement.
- Ça vous brûle ?
- Oui.
Où ça ? Montrez-moi
avec votre main où ça vous brûle.
Là.
- C’est que à cet endroit-là ?
Ça ne fait pas mal ailleurs ?
- Non.
Là, vous avez mal quand je vous touche ?
- Oui...
- Oui ?
C’est la première fois que
ça lui fait mal à cet endroit-là,
qu’il ressent ce genre de douleur.
- On va vous mettre
la petite ceinture par sécurité.
- Théo du coup, tu peux
nous expliquer ce qu’il s’est passé ?
- Une personne qui avait
du mal à respirer
et qui avait une douleur
au niveau du thorax.
Donc là, on l’emmène à l’hôpital
pour faire des examens
et voir ce qu’il a.
Là, mon collègue il va vous tenir,
vous allez vous mettre debout et on va
vous installer sur le brancard, d’accord ?
Vous vous mettez bien au fond, la tête ici.
Ça va mieux là ?
Non ? C’est toujours comme tout à l’heure ?
On peut être réveillés une fois,
deux fois, trois fois,
six fois, sept fois par nuit.
Il faut faire des micro-siestes
après chaque intervention.
- Ceux qui étaient en ambulance tout le temps,
des fois ils n’avaient même pas
le temps de manger carrément.
- Ah oui, ou des fois on mange à 16h.
C’est là qu’on rigole bien avec les copains.
C’est là qu’on fait les connaissances surtout.
- Oui, on fait tout.
Là, il y a le chef de la cuisine qui fait à manger
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure,
après on lave les couloirs,
on lave les douches.
Là, comme mission, on doit sortir les poubelles,
on doit les mettre dehors.
- Donc sapeur-pompier,
ce n’est pas juste les interventions,
il y a aussi du travail, du boulot.
Rien que l’alarme du téléphone,
il y a des gens qui vont dire :
"Oh non relou, je ne me lève pas
pour aller au travail."
Ça les saoule.
Eux, t’as une alarme qui sonne :
"Bim ! Bim ! Bim !..."
À 3h du matin, tu te réveilles,
tu descends par une rampe,
tu montes dans un camion,
tu te lèves et tu pars direct.
Il faut être passionné pour faire ça.
C’est pour ça, tu vois, que je suis admiratif.
C’est des trucs comme ça,
ils sont toujours au taquet.
Toujours sous adrénaline,
parce qu’on ne sait jamais
sur quoi on va tomber.
C’est ce qu’on appelle ni plus ni moins
que le baromètre de la forme.
La personne qui monte la planche,
monte dans les camions,
si elle ne monte pas la planche,
elle ne monte pas dans les camions.
C’est très physique mais après,
c’est surtout une technique.
Je pense que Riadh, avec
de l’entraînement, il peut y arriver.
- Après, il faut que tu prennes un contrat,
engage-toi à la brigade
et tu monteras dans les camions.
Pour vulgariser la chose,
on va réaliser une lance sur échelle.
C’est-à-dire qu’on va dresser l’échelle
aérienne ici qui fait 30 mètres
et on va réaliser une lance
tout en haut de l’échelle.
- On en apprend tous les jours à chaque fois,
à chaque manœuvre, ça change.
On va voir.
Ça va aller.
- Donc là, il est monté
à plus de 30 mètres, normal.
Et là, il est en train de se faire
un petit dispositif pour rester accroché.
- Il faut que tu te soutiennes
avec ta jambe qui est crochetée là,
il faut que ton pied repose sur un échelon.
- Et il y a son chef
qui donne des instructions.
- Il a à peu près 15 kilos de matériel sur le dos.
- Du vertige et de la peur.
C’est ce que je ressens actuellement,
je dis la vérité.
Après eux non, mais
c’est des sapeurs-pompiers.
Moi, je suis un être humain.
Ce sont des choses que je ne serais pas capable
de faire, moi, en tant qu’être humain.
Tu sais, c’est 30 mètres quoi.
Tu tombes, tu meurs.
Tu tombes comme une crêpe.
- Souvent, sur les gros feux, on peut rester des heures.
On est limités avec l’air qu’on respire
dans les bouteilles une demi-heure.
Si on ne fait pas trop d’efforts,
on peut rester une demi-heure
et après, en fait, on peut aller
changer nos bouteilles et revenir.
C’est pour ça que le but,
c’est d’être assis confortablement.
Impressionné par le poids,
le poids de la lance.
Je ne pensais pas que c’était aussi lourd
mais je pense que ça va.
Après tenir une demi-heure comme ça
pour attaquer un feu,
ça va être plus compliqué.
On vient d’arriver à Gare de l’Est,
donc, assistance à la personne.
En arrivant à Gare de l’Est,
j’ai failli tomber dans les pommes.
J’ai été prise de sueurs froides et de douleurs,
j’avais les jambes coupées.
Et du coup, je suis allée au petit casino
en bas de Gare de l’Est
et ils ont appelé le personnel adapté
et ils se sont très bien occupés de moi.
On va aller à l’hôpital pour
faire des examens complémentaires.
Déjà nous, avec ce qu’on a vu
sur le multiparamétrique,
il n’y avait rien d’alarmant, d’accord ?
Donc déjà, ça peut vous rassurer,
après on va juste faire une vérification
plus approfondie à l’hôpital.
Pour déjà 1, vous rassurer
et pour être sûr qu’il n’y a
vraiment rien, d’accord ?
Parmi les premières constantes
qu’on prend nous,
après on va transmettre
à la coordination médicale.
Donc le chef d’agrès va transmettre
les premières informations à la coordination
et suite à ça, le médecin va nous dire
justement la conduite à tenir :
si on l’emmène à l’hôpital
ou s’il a un SMUR qui va se déplacer
ou une ambulance de réanimation, etc.
Ils s’entraînent deux fois par jour.
Donc ça fait vraiment partie de leur quotidien.
Entraînement le matin, course à pied,
pour le cardio, le footing et tout.
Et le soir comme ça, enfin l’après-midi,
ils font de la corde, de la musculation.
Donc le sport ça fait vraiment partie de leur vie.
Ça leur permet d’être toujours
au point physiquement.
S'il y a besoin, par exemple, tu montes beaucoup
d’escaliers, tu portes des gens des fois
donc tu as besoin d’être en forme, affûté.
Je vais essayer après mais...
je ne vais pas monter comme ça moi.
J’ai peur que ma main… que je lâche
trop longtemps ma main...
Pourquoi je m’inquiète, il y a
les pompiers dans la salle les gars.
- Allez vas-y. On ne réfléchit plus.
- Allez !
- Voilà, c'est comme une traction.
- Allez, encore une !
C’est bien d’aller jusqu’au rouge ?
- Ouais, ouais c’est bien.
- C’est vrai ?
Si je n’avais pas fait de vidéo,
je pense que je me serais engagé.
Clairement.
Ça donne un sens à ta vie de ouf
parce que tu aides les gens,
tu te sens important, tu te sens utile.
Quand on t’appelle, tu y vas,
c’est comme si tu étais un super héros.
C’est un très, très beau métier.
Ils ont un engagement de ouf en fait,
parce qu’ils sont toujours au taquet,
toujours à 100 %,
avec les gens ils sont au top,
rien à dire.
Ils sont gentils, ils sont drôles,
ils s’adaptent à toutes les situations.
Donc beaucoup d’admiration
parce que ce sont des gens
qui mettent de côté tout
ce qui est amis, famille et tout
pour se consacrer aux autres, en fait.
Et ça, c’est ouf.
Au nom du général commandant la brigade,
je vous élève à la distinction
de première classe
à compter du 1er avril 2019.
Repos. Vous pouvez l’applaudir.